You Can Get Fit Fast for summer with
fast Fit Body Sculpting who are the
sponsors of this next segment Doug Zucco
the owner of Fast Fit Body Sculpting is
here to tell us more welcome to the show
thanks for having me how did all of this
start
well I was the guy that worked out twice
a day eight right did all the right
things I walked out of the gym on
October 2nd of 2014 had a heart attack
oh my gosh right outside the gym uh-huh
so well there you are yeah so I wake up
in the recovery room the doctors tell me
how lucky I was but I was scared to
death because I was already working out
you know two three hours a day right and
what was I going to do because
everything I was doing wasn't working
and the problem was because of visceral
fat visceral fat what is visceral fat
visceral Fat's the fat that's under the
muscle so you know the jiggly fat on the
outside I think we have a diagram yeah
anywhere you can touch some jiggly fat
that's that's subcutaneous fat that's
right under the skin but visceral fat is
under the muscle so a lot of people you
know are built pretty good they look
pretty good they don't even realize they
have visceral fat okay yeah so then how
can we tell if we had like what's the
sign how can you tell if you have
visceral fat you didn't know you had it
you worked out all the time how can you
tell you have it you had a six-pack on
the outside but I had a little bit of a
bulging belly right you see a lot of
weight lifters like that you know just
you know we do a total body analysis
when you come to fast we're looking at
you before and after okay go on yeah you
know I you work out so hard you got to
relate to people that are so frustrated
they're in their 40s 50s and they're
even older and they can't lose anything
right the midsection just sort of gets
out of control okay it's because of
visceral fat because no matter how hard
you work out no matter how good you eat
visceral fat will not be reduced and we
have some before and afters to look at
we have Jose here's the first one to
take a look at take a look at Jose and
tell me more about Jose and his journey
Jose was a commander of the Navy and he
was in risk of getting thrown out of the
Navy first physique right
23 pounds later look at Jose he's ripped
he looks amazing took him about four
months to do that okay amazing let's
take a look at Frank
Frank another guy 75 years old a lot a
lot of fat gone 45 pounds of fat gone
he's not at any risk anymore he's he
looks great looks fantastic jamar's next
let's take a look at Jamar oh my gosh
these Transit Transformations are
amazing George 72 years old and and now
he looks like he's 30. I mean it's
amazing but look at this midsection uh
just you know visceral fat gone we have
about 30 seconds let's take a look at
Judy Judy look that's amazing results
here Doug 21 pounds of fat Gone Gone
just like that that's fantastic and and
you guys have the answer to visceral fat
we have the answer to both subcutaneous
and visceral it's very healthy doesn't
hurt anything no side effects just makes
you feel and look amazing well the proof
is in the pudding and you and in those
photos Doug thank you so much for
joining us we appreciate it and thank
you again to fast Fit Body Sculpting for
sponsoring this segment they have three
locations Summerlin Centennial and
Henderson visit
fastfit.visitfast.fit or call 800
fastfit for more information and don't
forget they got a special offer their
first 20 callers will get out this 60
percent off Las Vegas now we'll be right
back
[Music]